on many levels i think there are a lot
of democrats whose hatred
for donald trump and his administration
and his supporters
overshadowed their support and love for
their country
and standing up for the rule of law and
standing up for america's
institutions
was getting people to scream stop
selling andy knows book
in your hometown a part of your
marketing strategy it's
pretty good free advertising
it was not part of the strategy but a
lot of people did end up hearing about
the book because of the
six day effort by antifa to get it
banned
which uh unfortunately was partially
successful in that portland's largest
bookstore
uh immediately came out and said they
would not stock it on its
shelves and this is a bookstore by the
way
um a very popular portland institution
that
every year dedicates um a week to
books that are censored and banned so um
there's sad irony there
too banned to be part of the unbanned
book
week correct that's serious but
obviously
the elephant in the room is that almost
everyone's gonna buy your book from
amazon
or barnes nobles or whatever
yeah i hope so and i i mean i'm just
you know the goal is to get people
informed about what's happening
and i think there's a lot of
misconceptions about antithea
antifa out there from both the left and
the right and
this book tries to explain in in one
place where people can understand
the ideology the history and how they
organize
and what what all that comes together
actually looks like in practice so i go
into detail
particularly of what happened in the
pacific northwest of the united states
throughout 2020
my home city of portland which i've had
to flee because of
death threats against me we had more
than 120
nightly days of violence so in your
country britain you
had sporadic violence that happened last
year
um imagine if that was reoccurring day
after day after day for months on end
and that's what happened in my city and
it's still ongoing
it's terrifying man so let's start who
are
antifa the
antifa claim to be anti-fascists
they're actually anarchist communists
who
are really working to destabilize
governments particularly the
jurisdictions in the united states
because
they want to ultimately overthrow the us
so they take inspiration from historical
anarchist communist
communes and they try to carry out these
experiments wherever they can and to do
so in america
was always a pipe dream for them given
how strong law enforcement institutions
are and the military etc
but in 2020 things just completely was
split upside down
when after george floyd died then
the every excuse on the
fringe extreme far left to carry out
violence was excused in the mainstream
left
and it was in that context that antifa
blm
for example in seattle and
the largest city in the pacific
northwest they actually claimed
sovereign territory or territory that
they said was sovereign from the united
states for more than three weeks and
they actually have the blessing
of the city council as well as the mayor
and immediately this
despite what the media was saying
describing it as a block party
summer of love um i spent time there a
week undercover
right to pass out in the book um it
devolved um
within days into an area where there
were shootings and people ended up
getting killed
and murdered there what's the end goal
that antifa won
antifa's vision of so-called
anti-fascism
means a world without nation states
without borders without capitalism
because and this is where their ideology
is very based on
these old left-wing theories
particularly um
critical theories of where these are
there are these
interlocking systems of oppression so
they believe for example the u.s is a
fascist
imperialistic state because it's a state
that propagates capitalism around the
world and capitalism
uh is what is linked to
white supremacy and racism and fascism
as well
so they're wanting to end
not just the united states but i think
more
what we're seeing now like we're
actually having success is
delegitimizing and attacking
systematically
the ideas that make up the united states
are actually any western
liberal democracy so they go extremely
hard against freedom of expression
that's one of their core
tenets that's why they carry out acts of
wanton
political violence against their
political opponents because
in their um re-definite
remaking of words um violence
is not actual violence it's
having the wrong idea so when they are
attacking people that they
accused of being fascists or white
supremacists
um and they use that label on anyone by
the way
um in their mind they call it
self-defense because if you
have the idea uh that they called
fascists that is an attack on them
therefore they need to preemptively
physically attack you and destroy
property
and you know this is all it's it's
you know it would be like i would like
to just laugh because it's so
outrageous and obviously um
a charade and a fossil but a foss
but um unfortunately they've been given
legitimacy in our paper as a record in
in your country as well as mine
and people who
are on the last but not the extreme
french far left
have become allies with them because
they really do think
that uh when trump was elected that that
was um
ascendant american fascism that we were
on the
precipice of another holocaust all of
this was bogus
and it was um just
a pretense for them to carry out their
agendas
destabilizing governments local local
governments and they've been able to do
that with quite success
um and i'm not exaggerating what i'm
saying
you can read as can see in the book how
because the
local officials gave them the space
to do what they were doing for so long
throughout 2020
they really have created and embedded
these networks and systems to maintain
rights ongoing because that does take a
lot of organizing it takes times it
takes
connections it takes people it takes
money all of that
which they've been able to establish and
they've been trying to export
these bloop um blew
um these prints and plans
um to other cities which is why
uh later on after george fuller died in
later months when there was rioting
in wisconsin some of the people who
arrested there drove
all the way or flew in from other parts
of the country like the pacific
northwest
it's interesting to me to hear you talk
about the
potential origin of the mainstream of
antifa
in the u.s being trump's election back
in 2016 2017
what do you think antitheta thinks of
joe biden there's probably a hope
that after biden won the election
perhaps the antifa violence would calm
down
yeah so that didn't happen
we're now many weeks until
2021 months after trump had won the
election in november
and there's been more than a dozen riots
that have happened
in the pacific northwest um
some people were surprised they thought
oh these are dumb uh these abiding
supporters
no they're not actually if you look at
what they say look at the banners for
example one of the banners that they
carried on the
their inauguration day riot in portland
was a large one that said we don't want
biden we want revenge
and there's a large image of a question
called rifle
if that wasn't thoughtful enough
and so they don't recognize
the american government period they're
working to overthrow it they don't
recognize
any president the legitimacy of any
president
so that means opposing before the
current administration yes opposing
trump
but opposing any administration that
would replace trump anyways
because they don't see the u.s
government as legitimate they're viewed
as a fascist state that must be
overthrown
so this is what i mean when i say that
people on the mainstream left who have
been
feeding and feeding and growing this
beast because they shared a mutual enemy
in the trump administration or against
republicans whatever
well now this beast is too big
to slay and we've seen the violence
after carried out they've attacked
they've assaulted
the mayor of portland the mayor
important wheeler
is somebody who gave them the space to
grow
under his watch and they turned around
and has attacked him
they showed up to the homes of people on
city council uh
in portland for example who uh voted
against
um defunding the police so
and the thing is they're not getting
held accountable when they're carrying
out these criminal activities
it's not just that they're doing it it's
that they're doing it
and then doing it over and over and over
because there's no consequence
so one of the projects that i'm known
for is getting the
uh the public records of people who are
arrested at riots
and we have now a sample size and just
important of
around a thousand cases and the
overwhelming majority
by that i mean more than 90 percent how
the charge is immediately dropped
by the prosecutor who is a politician
it's an elected position
who campaigned on a so-called
progressive platform
and as soon as he came into office last
summer he uh
literally decriminalized the felony
rally that was one of the things that
will be automatically discharged so
um like
this is the reality of what's happening
in parts of america um it's not
hyperbole when the
doj last year described some parts of
the us
as as anarchist jurisdictions because
you do have a breakdown
of the rule of law the system's not
working
and these extremists are exploiting
civil rights human rights to carry out
their wanton violence
in the name of free speech and right to
protest
and unfortunately they've been given
cover you know i keep going back to the
media
because they wouldn't have been able to
do so much damage
if there wasn't this
antifa talking point that was mainstream
which claims that
people over property that the looting
and breaking and starting fires and
destroying buildings and distances
that's not violence because uh it's on
an inanimate
object like
this is like portland is really a
first world slum if you go to its
downtown
like they're trying to
create an environment where people don't
have trust in law enforcement on one
level and two
law enforcement just don't have the
resources to even respond
to crimes that are happening in the
cities we have a huge uptick
in most uh american urban areas
in violence
police officers across many many
departments are resigning in droves or
taking early retirement
so all the conditions that allowed
things to get so bad in 2020 they're all
still there
and trump was never a real variable that
was just a convenient excuse
that's terrifying man there's so many
points that i agree with there
specifically talking about how allowing
them to
embed in create these organizational
structures
and also sort of the intellectual
structures understanding how they need
to develop and then writing up you go
through basically a curriculum
in the book of how they indoctrinate and
train
new members into antifa but it's kind of
the same way that a cancer
grows you know if it's just one cell
that turns the other cells around it can
attack
but after a little bit of time if you
get too many cells they can metastasize
and actually turn into a genuine cancer
and that's a much bigger operation to
try and get rid of and
it seems to be the same i mean
a first world slum in somewhere like
portland
and wasn't it the homicide rate
increased by 200 percent
the most it's been in a number of
decades something like that
correct that's right thank you during
the height of the riots
so we've been having this unprecedented
unprecedented
unprecedented level rise in shootings
and
gun related homicides in portland and
this is
like antifa have been celebrating this
they're really happy
um because the whole they want
they say they want to abolish the
american criminal justice system
abolish police and all that but
what they essentially want to be is to
replace the police with their own
paramilitary type groups and
the cities under weak
police leadership under weak city
council and weak state leadership
have allowed them to do it and so i'm
not
even exaggerating when i say that
in last year in particular when the
riots were happening every night
parts of downtown were literally no go
zones in that they
had people patrolling their own militias
people who were armed with weapons
patrolling around to make sure that this
huge part of downtown right outside of
one of the
courthouses that they were trying weeks
on end to burn down
um that the only people who were there
were their allies and supporters and
members
so they've attacked countless number of
press
um as many people know they beat me
severely in 2019
and gave me a brain hemorrhage so
like they don't even hide the
extremism and the violence it's not like
they
do it behind closed doors they do it in
the open and it gets captured on video
and still people actually think that
we're dealing
with noble and anti-fascists who are
just opposing races
you said something in the book that i
really thought was a good
a good quote the intellectualizing of
their arguments tries to mask the
ruthlessness of their worldview
because it does have this you remember
when you were in school
and there was always that that kid that
had that was
a bit of a quicker reader and maybe had
a greater grasp of language
and would try and flummox people in a
schoolyard
dispute so actually your argument
doesn't have very much internal validity
there my friend and you're like
it just smacks massively of all of the
people who couldn't climb up a status
hierarchy normally in school
and are now trying to cover over what is
incredibly ruthless very militant by
using words that i don't think even they
understand they don't really make sense
in the context that they're using them
they're born out of a bunch of very
contradictory
uh and self-deceiving
uh philosophies most of which i'm gonna
guess they
might have read to tick the box on the
curriculum and then left it
it seems very self-defeating and
confused
yeah so their ideas are
coherent in that they these ideas are
coming from
20th and 19th century philosophers
anarchists and communists radical
thinkers um
if you look at the original text they're
very long and can be confusing so what
they
what the antifa do is
they come they compress those ideas into
pamphlets
and this is becomes the backbone of
their radicalizat radicalization
literature
that at all their rights they give out
when they were in
the autonomous zone in seattle uh chaos
um they were giving out this literature
and it's actually very similar to how
like the muslim brotherhood will
radicalize their numbers it's
compressing like
large attacks into these very easily
quick reads
that intellectualize political violence
intellectualize
violence against the state some of them
even give instructions on how to
make weapons how to seize territory
these are some of the things that i was
seeing in chat so i was really
shocked that the press at the time was
just completely
overlooking this ideological extremism
that was being preached
in the open there um and
um the you mentioned the curriculum part
that's from rose city altitude which is
the largest and oldest antifa
organization in the us
they're in portland go figure and you'll
see that
in every single way they are a formal
organization and
the book details it but like there's um
a recruitment process there's a vetting
process there's training there's
curriculum there's reading there's
discussions all these are done
secretively
and one of the places they did it was a
feminist bookstore
so like they they do a lot of activities
in the open
that we can see that are criminal and
they do a lot of other things behind
closed doors and this book
shines the light on both the pamphlets
sound like
tick-tock for anarchist philosophers
not just condensing things down into the
most easy to read
palatable way that they can do it you
mentioned about the structure and i
think that
it's interesting looking at the
structure of antifa
does it actually have a leader is it a
single entity
it is not a single entity so when
christopher wray who is the leader the
head of the
fbi when he gave testimony and said
antifa
is not an organization he's technically
correct but
he should have followed that up by
saying but there are
many antifa groups and organizations who
do share the same ideology whether they
have the answer
in the name or not and they are
connected to
net linking networks so that's why you
can have
rioters from portland or seattle
know how to link with the anarchist
communists who are in wisconsin which is
thousands and thousands of miles away or
linked with the
extremists and too far in dc very far
away as well
so he should have followed up on that so
but
that's the thing it is networks of
decentralized groups which
makes taking them out harder
but we're not even anywhere even near
that step because people
law enforcement federal law enforcement
publicly at least i don't know what
they're doing behind the scenes but
i don't i don't think they're even at
the stage where they even recognize
that there are these networks of groups
that are connected that do encrypted
communications through
signal and telegram they do things that
pretty much a lot of the jihadists do
they i mean it's not a coincidence that
their uniforms look similar i mean it's
meant to
instill fear in the public in addition
to being able to carry out
acts of criminality um with the cloak of
anonymity
so um i
i've been disappointed in the the
federal
law enforcement response under the trump
administration and um
i don't you know i have no confidence
that
with federal officials under the body
enemies i was going to say do you think
it is
it's going to get any better no
okay you've got a last one yeah it's um
it's so smart in one way for all that
you can
see it's self-contradictory and they
can't run a city
to save their lives literally because
people were dying inside of it and had
no running water and there was that
plant that vegetable plot that stopped
within the spade all of the plants died
within two days
you know i can i can keep a plant alive
for longer than two days right like and
i'm i'm
very not green fingered but yet there's
certain elements of
their operation that are incredibly
sophisticated and
all of the benefits that you see from
uh decentralized cryptocurrencies for
instance
where it's not held on one server it's
very very difficult to take down you
have this security everything's backed
up across multiple locations
you've basically got that ideologically
with antifa
yeah i'm glad you brought up the thing
about the garden because it is
it's amazing on uh you know just looking
at it but also
it's an anecdote that is actually what
i've seen
repeated over and over and that when it
comes to
building um being productive
anything like that they cannot do it
and yet they claim they want to
establish a utopia by abolishing
uh the system the system being
everything about the united states
but what they are really extremely good
at is destruction
in creating misery that's what they uh
that's all they can really do and that's
so you notice when they are most
successful
it's in carrying out acts of political
violence in writing and arson
attacks and homicides um that's what
they're really good at when it comes to
actually building their own car means
that they purport to be
working towards it leads nowhere you
know uh
chaos essentially was a it was a wealth
welfare state that depended on donations
from
foolish liberals who were pouring in
tens of thousands of dollars into these
venmos and cash outs so that people
would bring in
both of water and food 24 7 intense
do you think antifa would have righted
outside the capital if trump had won
yes i think the violence that we saw
in response to um
the death of george floyd would have
been repeated and may have been even
amplified
because the i mean they were given
uh essentially they're okay from
democrats
so uh they would have had liberals who
were
supporting that right so trump were to
win um
and i think the
you know one thing about the response to
the election let's say from the right
particularly on the 6th of january when
there's a capital hill siege
like i um
i was furious seeing these hollow
condemnations
from democrats people
who were describing it essentially as
another 911 in america
when those acts of violence against the
state
and wars were carried out night after
night after night
in other major american cities by
antiphon blm
because people were encouraging of it or
um they actually even were we're sending
out some of the links to the
crowdfunding campaigns
kamala harris did that people who worked
on the joe biden presidential campaign
did that
um so
what happened at the capitol which
should absolutely be condemned
but those same acts were done in
portland and worth actually because the
people in portland
over time they became more sophisticated
and they kept returning they would bring
different weapons
they would bring explosives they brought
fives they brought guns
um projectiles i write about all
of their acts of terrorism in the book
and they even brought i think what was
most shocking was seeing them bring
power tools so they could try to cut
into the building
so that and they tried on more than one
occasion to barricade the building
and talking about the federal courthouse
in downtown so this is a federal
property in portland
so that's comparable to the federal
property in dc
these people actually tried to barricade
law enforcement
federal law enforcement inside and try
to set the building of buyers so they
could kill anybody inside
this is the types acts that they were
doing and the way the media was covering
at the time
were describing law enforcement as
trump's
uh secret police trump's gestapo
and occupying force people who were
hurting peaceful protesters
what's the difference like i know that
left at the moment seems to be in with
the media
and it's just a lot cooler and it more
easily accepted
the talking points that come from the
left it seems that the left is
affiliated with compassion whereas the
right is affiliated with bigotry at
least in the legacy media
but what is it what why is it that you
get so much condemnation
for the capital hill riots and you get
so much emission for what antifa we're
doing
it's because on many levels
i think there are a lot of democrats who
whose hatred for donald trump and his
administration and his supporters
over shadowed their support
and love for their country in standing
up for the rule of law and standing up
for america's
institutions
[Music]
i don't feel good saying that because um
you know i
try to be bipartisan in my outreach
in a lot of this book i'm hoping will
reach people on the left so they can
recognize the threat
that auntie proposes to
american liberalism um
but just this pure hatred of
the former president in what they
thought he stood for
just in their eyes legitimized all these
acts of extremism
and so um
what's worse is i think like a certain
precedent has been said
he's obviously if you um i talked to
people uh who are sympath who were
are sympathetic to the right-wing siege
on capitol hill
and one of the responses and it wasn't
it didn't just happen in
dc there were other similar like violent
protests at other state capitals by
trump supporters
on that day and before that
and the people who are expressing
support for that their view is
will advance from the alam get to riot
over their cause and nothing
gets they face no legal consequence they
don't condemn their praise
well why do we have to be peaceful then
so this is the thing too like
antifa creates reactionary forces
as well and they know that actually
which is
why i mean everything about them their
existence
they have to justify by saying that
they're in opposition to something
that's why they say empty in front of
their name
so they do work to radicalize people on
the far right i think
they work to
terrorize people at their homes after
places employments get them fired
get them pushed off mainstream platforms
and push into
really scary places on the internet and
it's
like antifa are creating the things that
they say they're there to fight
actually absolutely i had a i did a
video about this
the other week talking about the tit for
tat mentality you do this to me and then
i come back a slightly
slightly more tough to you and then a
little bit more tough to me and then so
on and so forth
and it's just this endless spiral that i
don't think is going to slow down
the elephant in the room is that
fascists and white supremacists are not
around every corner like that
they're just not and the fact that
you have this culpable accusatory game
where you can say well that's that's
because of your implicit white supremacy
that's because you're being willfully
ignorant about it
that's essentially just um allowing the
theory to never be falsified
but they're not around every corner and
one thing
that other people have commented on as
well is
if antifa do get themselves
to the stage where they really really
rile up the right
like there are some people on the right
who are incredibly scary
they're significantly more trained and
they have a lot more guns
like the people on the right were
originally the military
threat a lot of them are going to be
ex-military uh i think you saw that with
some of the stats from arrests over the
last couple of weeks that a lot of them
did have military backgrounds
if it comes to a war between the two of
them
which hopefully it won't but if it does
i really
fear for antifa's hopes because
there's some lethal weapons coming from
the right
yeah so they recognize that certain
threat
uh they recognize that they're they're
radicalizing people on the far right in
the far right
some of them are armed but their
response has been
not to end the cycle of polarization
radicalization
their responses were gonna arm up too so
you see
um i write about in the book like this
um they don't issue guns or anything
like that
at their rights people are coming their
arms many of them have been
arrested for illegally carrying loaded
pistols
um they carry rifles openly when they
had chavs
for example they have their militia
guarding their hard borders
and these people were armed with rifles
revolvers pistols
etc um part of prorose city antifa part
of the
training process included how to shoot
guns and such
so um they're preparing themselves for a
war not just a war against the state but
war against
people on the far right or the
militarized right whatever
so um and they're not afraid to kill and
[Music]
but as we've been discussing
they don't really have any metrics that
are used
to um differentiate
differentiate against people who are
let's say a trump supporter versus like
somebody who's a neo-nazi
they consider them all the same and they
think the response
they can apply the same response to all
of them which is why
last summer in portland at the height of
the riots
they one of the antifa volunteered
security
shot and killed a trump supporter
and then fled the state and went to
hiding
eventually was killed by federal
authorities
he had a pistol on him at the time in
the car where he was shot and killed
there was a rifle so i'm talking about
michael rhino
but he's not the only antsy fighter
who's killed there's been other people
as well but we don't know their names as
destroyers because it doesn't
fit this myopic focus
that the mainstream press have on
their reporting and extremism which only
focuses on right to extremism
and many times they over exaggerate
things as well
making people because for example this
army that antifa does
they look at the reporting and all that
and say oh see look at the threat of the
far right
look at this rather far right that's why
we need to arm up
so um it's
like the media has been so complicit in
creating this whole
context for political violence to thrive
particularly on the far left
and when it's time to report accurately
on
the extremism of antifa or blm
they're not there to do it um when
antifa
tell live streamers and journalists
you can't record us while we're writing
go listen
so a lot of the footage that we've been
seeing
particularly in the past like five
months or so have been
brave independent journalists who record
secretively or with body cameras or
they'll do it and then they get beat up
for it so
you know whereas the legacy media
they'll they won't go into there
they just won't even cover it you know
they're still calling these rioters
just protesters you went
undercover in the capitol hill
autonomous zone and you're talking
quite detail about what it felt like
obviously the last time
that you were in a group like that or
one of the last times you're in a group
like that you were pretty badly beaten
then
developed a little bit of ptsd with
regards to being in groups
you said that one of your friends
convinced you that you should go
like how much convincing did it take
from that friend and then can you
tell us about what it was like walking
into
chaz blacked up and obviously incredibly
nervous
so after i was beaten in the summer 2019
which by the way has led to no arrests i
still had had
no justice and that part of that beating
was actually caught on camera
but um that aside um
i did develop an intense fear of
being in public because when i was
beaten it was completely
it started from behind punches
to the head and there was just and i was
in front of essentially the main police
station in downtown so what happened
within eyesight of law enforcement and
it was right by all these courthouses so
it should be an area that is
you would think is safe to walk down in
in the united states
but it wasn't so um
but i fast forward a year later and all
the various therapies that i've had
to address some of the um
cognitive physical psychological issues
of the attack
um this friend of mine was just
he was he was encouraging me to go to
chaz because
it was such like a surreal like it was
unbelievable what had happened
like we knew from looking at the real
coverage
of what antifa was saying and putting
out themselves that this was a territory
that they
claimed um as separate from the us it
wasn't like just this block party that
the press was
um claiming it to be so i was like
for me it was i had that fear and i was
like but i had to
deal with it in any way and to go up
because i knew there wouldn't be very
many people who would get the truth out
and um wore their
uniform and it was very terrifying at
times to be
so scrutinized because just because you
mask up
and look like them that doesn't make you
like just one of them
they're suspicious because they actually
do know they recognize
for example the voice and body movements
of their comrades
so there's somebody in there who's
dressed like one of them but
for example is not participating in
rioting or violence
they questioned that so i spent five
days
five days there and unfortunately on my
last day i was outed
um and i had to flee for my life
literally
from chas and the sad thing is this
happened right in front of the
uh east police station but it was an
abandoned station it was one where
rioters had
um caused the whole place to be
barricaded up and police had
completely evacuated from this whole six
block area
in seattle so yeah i spent uh
a night time there particularly
well i so i was during the day going to
accommodation elsewhere
and then at night going so you went you
went nocturnal for a week
yes all the interesting all the
interesting stuff happens at night
yeah because that's that's when the the
press would leave
you know the press would only say that
during the day ben and jerry's who was
giving out free
ice cream i couldn't believe that free
ice cream cones
that's right they did that all during
the day at night this is when you would
see
um essentially warlord-like
figures attempting to vie for control
over the area
there was a drug kingpins and stuff like
that right rolling around in open-back
trucks
there's people with criminal back known
criminal backgrounds who were going
around with their own
entourage of people who were carrying
weapons yes
[ __ ] so what else did you see on the
night time what did you see that hasn't
been
reported
fights were breaking out all over there
wasn't unity in this area at all
because you had essentially
uh different buying ideologies so there
were antifa there and they
marked their territory all over with
their symbols
and graffiti calling for police to be
killed
the blm were more they viewed themselves
as more
along the lines of like revolutionary
marxists
like ones that you saw in the 70s like
black panthers and stuff like that
so they weren't down with want and
property destruction they didn't think
that was useful
so they didn't that did cause some
friction
and it boils over as well and
essentially um
antifun won't admit this but there
they naturally racially segregated
themselves in there
the white people who were in antifa
states stood um stuck together as a
clique
whereas the uh black marxists uh
they were together in their separate
area so
you know for this area that claimed to
be founded on anti-racism and social
justice there was
racial segregation and then on top of
that they had a 100
black homicide rate 100 black shooting
victim rate
talk to me about how you got discovered
of being andy now
um that is a story that readers should
look for in the book because i haven't
really talked about it before but i will
say
that it involved somebody that i had
written about before um a
transactional antifa militant
who has a criminal record and has been
i've identified as
being at many riots in the seattle area
and so this individual was really
scrutinizing
my social media to sort of try to
work out and find out exactly where i
was
and all that so these are and it wasn't
just this individual
she was connected to a whole network of
these
online anti-phi activists who were
working trying to identify exactly where
i was
and unfortunately um through my own
experience
left certain crumbs that i've learned
to grow from so they become very very
good identifying outsiders it's actually
really scary to go and record their
rides which is why you don't see a lot
of videos coming out now
close up of them like destroying this
businesses and properties it's been
independent journalists who have come up
with creative ways
to record because it's so dangerous well
it's not just
that they found you i saw a video on
your youtube
of a guy who looks a little bit like you
walking down the street and everyone's
sticking their fingers up at him
it's so bad that someone that looks like
andy no now is an
enemy of antifa yeah so
in portland i was undercover a lot but
they
would never know when i was there when i
was not so i had to
change my tactics and come up with
different ways
and so they were so overzealous in
trying to track me down and find me
that i believe on more than five
occasions they misidentified people on
their side because that person was a
male
per male of the east asian heritage that
you know just based on sharing the same
race as me they thought was me
uh yeah it's been very embarrassing to
them because
you know they say they're anti-racist
and they just they think that every
the most pejorative thing in the world
yeah every asian male is andy no
there's this bit in that video where the
guys stood in front he's
saying you do realize why you're here
you're
you're being very racist and you're
supposed to be anti-fascists
this is the second time that it's
happened to me at march
and this donkey of a girl stood next to
the person
holding the camera goes well it seems
like you're doing it on purpose
and you're like doing what on purpose
being asian like it seems like you're
doing it on purpose
i couldn't believe it
it's unbelievable um what about the
reasons that young people are getting
attracted to this like when i was
18 to 24 i wasn't really bothered about
fighting for
revolutionary capitalist throat tear
down with
anarcho communists like i started to go
on a night out
why are people getting attracted to
these movements
so broadly um i would divide
the anti-fun militants into sort of two
kinds you have
people one side of them who are
um in white collar professions and
that's why
i look into the backgrounds of the
people who are arrested at these riots
because surprisingly or not many of them
are professors academics they're
journalists
they work in medicine visit with
professors have been registered nurses
things that
people who are like doing respectable
jobs people have families people who are
attorneys
these are people who have uh without
exception been exposed to
radical latin ideologies through
academia
and it's just slipped i mean it's the
whole takeover
of the american academy um
from you know it's not just the social
sciences where you see
that you know you don't just have to be
in
a queer studies program or a
indigenous studies program you you're
seeing these ideologies
also in medicine and such in engineering
and this that so these are like the
intellectual the people who have
privilege of education
and wealth and income who think that
they are
um being important allies in this fight
against fascism
and then the other side of the antifa
includes people who
are economically unstable
they're vagrants many of them people
dealing with mental
health issues people dealing with gender
dysphoria disproportionately you'll
notice that
many of them um i've discovered have
relatively recently transitioned from
agenda to another one or back again or
something like that
um so these are people who are not
just vulnerable and some of the
backgrounds actually
are very sad and what are they looking
for they're looking for belonging
they're looking for a sense of cohesion
well this is the so the psychological
aspect i think of
why vulnerable people are joining is
because
they have real grievances right let's
say
they are unable to find
work they don't want to work they uh
have no money
they are dealing with all these issues
personally
and instead of working on improving
themselves and the people around them
they're taking it out
they're blaming society at large so
these are people who feel really
justified in their destruct
wanton destruction and looting and
violence
because they feel they've been wrong and
this is
this is why this theme of revenge
repeats itself a lot in their chance and
all that
um these are people who need help and
instead they've been pulled into
a violent extremist cult that promises
to give them that gives them community
it gives them a new
purpose and life it
also makes
the villains into the heroes i mean i
think these people
probably recognize on one level that
they're really hurting
their communities when they do this they
go out to small businesses
but they've been so blinded by an
ideology where they believe that now
they're
doing something virtuous by doing all
this so
this is the really dangerous part of
antifa is that it
makes people think wickedness is good
and so they will stop at nothing to
further
agenda and that means killing when
necessary
stabbing people when needed beating them
on the head in the face
including elderly people elderly women
who have stepped into charge intervened
it is that element of the vulnerable
the homeless the vagrants the people
with mental health issues being
recruited
essentially into look we have the answer
we can make you feel like you're
contributing we can make you feel a part
of something
as you said right at the beginning it's
much it's such a trope to say it's much
easier to tear something down than it is
to build something up but it would
appear that antifa are pretty [ __ ] at
doing anything that isn't tearing
something down
but anyone can do it thankfully breaking
a glass window requires no
qualifications and almost no training
i totally hadn't realized it's
far too cliche to presume that all of
antifa
are upper working class or middle class
people
from nice areas with good mums and dads
who are just sort of
luxury smashing their way through the
afternoon but
the way that people who perhaps have the
intellectual capacity to manipulate
these less fortunate people and turn
them into the vanguard
of these movements that is really
insidious that makes me
feel quite uneasy yes that's a great
analysis yes
these people who the intellectuals the
professors the academics those who are
in stable
backgrounds are using
these vulnerable people as henchmen and
goons to carry out
max of criminal violence and on the rare
occasion that
law enforcement and prosecutors do
something it's another drop in the
bucket if one of them happens to be
sentenced to prison
what's the relationship between antifa
and blm
so in 2020 there was a in my view a
fusion of the two movements um
and i saw that most clearly in antifa
black bloc volunteering as on security
militia type groups for
blm events and
there was a lot of there's been a lot of
cross-pollination since 2016
between these two different ideologies
um
blm by the words and statements and
self-identification of their
their co-founders they identify as
marxists
and the people they venerate and
celebrate
are revolutionary marxists and some of
them
um are fugitives to cuba like assata
shakura who
was involved in the murder of the state
trooper
decades ago these are the type of people
that they
want to emulate whereas antifa
the anarchist side of them is very
important to it's
it's for them it's the fusion of anarchy
and communism together
so in many ways there are certain
what you would think would be barriers
to them coming together because
the blm people are not
trying to necessarily abolish
the state itself i think they're working
to try to
replace all the institutions with their
people so that they take power
with the state um but as
of right now they share a common
ideology in
their opposition to militant opposition
to law enforcement
to the rule of law to property rights
to um the rights
in america the conservative right so
they have enough common enemies and
common goals right now that they are
working together
but i think charles was a particular
telling thing
that when they let's say have had had
some success and they were forced to be
together
that's when these differences came out
and
but this is where antifa has taken a lot
of intersectional theory as well
so they were deferential to
the black marxist militants in chaz um
just because they happen to be black so
how do you mean they were deferential
what were they doing they were scared to
openly challenge some of these
warlord-type figures who happen to be
black because they didn't want to be
perceived as racist within their own
community i was going to say are they
scared of
challenging them because they're black
or scared of challenging them because
they're a warlord
they're because they're black
because that would that would undermine
the grievance hierarchy that they're
supposed to be
in favor of correct yeah
so you can see their ideologies uh is
very biased nature very destabilizing
even within
the people who are on the far left so
um but as of now they're uh in unison
for the most part
and anti-first chance are no different
from blm chance
um the graffiti is no different
and they have a common enemy in taking
down and destroying
the founding ideals of america when you
think about
some black values though i think
it doesn't strike massively for me with
tearing down institutions you know you
think about some of the things that
were championing young black
kids to get into you know that you can
perform in academics that you can
go into whatever job role that you want
you can proceed and win
within the structure as it is if there's
no structure left then
you can't win anything yeah which is why
you see
some uh black american community
activists who have come
out against the anti-violence in some
cities
because they're like what what the hell
are you doing you're attacking
businesses are owned by black people you
are hurting our community you're
economically
affecting us during a time when kogat
has already been so devastating
but these antifa people they see
they don't view those um black activists
as
allies to view them as people who
because they're still willing to work
within the system
and they're not willing to abolish it
they're not true allies so they don't
they're not willing to um heed some of
their pleads
for them um to stop being so disruptive
uh instead they'll find like these token
black anarchists
or people of color anarchists and say
see our movement is diverse and it's
being led
by people of color what happens next
marin
beginning of 2021 at the moment biden's
inauguration was
recent what's your prediction for the
next
year um
just a continuation of what we've seen
before just routine
political violence in the streets and
law enforcement
not being able to respond in people not
being
convicted much less prosecuted what
would you do
where would you go from here if you were
trying to give some advice to
policymakers law officials government
officials
what would be realistic strategies that
you could see to
stem this tide or perhaps even reverse
it
so um the federal government um
in the past has dealt with networks of
criminal gangs like the mafia and other
groups
and so there are already laws on the on
the books that i think could be applied
in helping to break apart some of these
networks
um that's one thing that can be done i
think
another thing though um and this can't
be done without the involvement of
liberals is for the left to
systematically detach itself from the
far left extremist um
i'm not sure if they're willing to do
that right now because the
in my view overton window of what was
allowed on the left has moved pretty far
out there
so um you know
no matter what happens this year we
already have this mainstreaming of this
argument that
property destruction and lootings in the
cause of
racial justice is just um
attacking and hurting law enforcement or
trying to burn down government property
for the cause of racial justice is right
so
um that
claim has to be challenged from the left
but
i don't see um with the direction
that they are continuing to move until
hard left identitarianism um i don't see
them coming up to
uh expel the fringes um the fringe
voices
in uh on their side by trump no longer
being in power though there is one
less very big thing for them to
rally around as a unified force
yes but that's why in 2020 they weren't
really rallying so much in opposition to
trump they did that in 2016 17 18
19 but in 2020 it was rallying against
police and policing is an institution
uh departments are going to be around
regardless of which administration is in
power
so that's why you see them writing still
after biden one
i mean cnn there's a story where they
were interviewing people
why were you writing on inauguration day
and their responses
we're still fighting for racial justice
because the system
itself is racist so this is it's like
you said earlier
their claims can never be
um actually challenged in their mind
they can never be falsified
it's always like you know we're fighting
for george floyd if it's not george
floyd
we're fighting against um the
the institution of law enforcement
because that is a form of
america uh modern-day slavery it is not
that
it's capital capitalism because that is
in a system of white supremacy
so it's always something you know and um
all it takes is for the next viral video
of some um deadly encounter with
law enforcement and a black person for
thousands of leftists to take to the
street and then for anti-flood to
exploit
those gatherings to turn them into riots
in mass looting events
um it's a playbook that they've mastered
incredibly well
and law enforcement have been neutered
in their ability to respond
because any time police use uh use force
justifiably you see what happens
more news stories more more headlines
yeah i can't get over how
clever the antifa name is
it's like it's the precise opposite
of everything that they're actually
doing in terms of the way that they act
but it immediately frames any press
coverage or anything that anyone says
with an immediate positive spin in their
direction it's like why wouldn't i want
to be anti-fascist of course i want to
be i want to be four
fascists fascists sound awful but
what they're actually doing is just
hiding behind a very clever name
like if all it takes is to name myself
not the thing that i am
it doesn't bode well for sexual
predators does it but imagine all that
harvey weinstein needed to do was
start a movement called not a rapist and
then he'd have been fine
like that's not the way it works in any
other uh
form of the world but because the
arrows of causation are so muddy and
because there is some grievance there
are
justifiable problems in the world which
need to be fixed
but when this is the problem and this is
the response
it uh it often devolves into violence
which is what we've seen
yeah so i'm glad you focus on the name
because
a lot of people do get hung up on that
people on the left are like
i like politicians they cannot
come out vocally and condemning antifa
because um
correct exactly and it's such i can't
believe such a juvenile
childish
so many people right and have made them
cowards
like i don't care what amsterdam calls
themselves i just
i look at their ideology i look at their
actions and i look what they call for
it it's their what they do are acts of
terrorism so um to me
it's immaterial what they call
themselves it doesn't matter and
unfortunately for my opposition to them
have been smeared as a fascist
propagandist
and have been beaten and have had to
go into hiding um so
but um i mean what's important is that
my my book hasn't been cancelled so it's
still it's still out there
or will be released very soon and um i'm
hoping
people just become better informed on
this threat that we're dealing with
right now certainly will be unmasked
inside antifa's radical plan to destroy
democracy will be linked in the show
notes below
where else should people go to check out
your stuff uh andy
ngo.com is my website perfect
and thank you enjoy the remainder of
your time in my lovely country
thank you